[Musique]
la fameuse cloche de 16 tonnes de la
cathédrale saint paul a résonné dans
toute la ville pour rendre hommage à la
reine
acclamé par la foule le prince william
et kate forme certainement le couple
royal le plus populaire de la dynastie
des windsor
on peut pas en dire autant du premier
ministre bruce johnson qui s'est fait
huer en arrivant la cathédrale mais
l'heure est à la célébration pour la
reine car pendant 70 ans elle aura
incarné la stabilité la continuité et
l'unité du pays
ils étaient nombreux pour lui dire merci
et moraliser ce moment unique de
l'histoire
l'émotion est palpable pour certains car
ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on voit
d'aussi près les membres de la famille
royale 40 en tout durant le service de
ce pour une seule chine organes aubry
est au deuil on est déçu qu'il ne soit
pas là a dit il me comprend elle a un
inconfort et ce ne serait pas juste de
lui mettre de la pression entre autres
aspects de son esprit et la rajoute
celui ci
à 73 ans le prince charles son
successeur est là pour la représenter
en stéréo et nous
sommes heureux que vous soyez bien en
selle ans archevêque de youb durant la
cérémonie faisant référence à l'amour de
la règle pour les chevaux
seul absent le prince andrew qui aurait
été déclaré positif à la cueillette 19
mai prince harry meyen michael était
présent même s'ils ont renoncé à leurs
titres royaux
[Musique]
je ne les soutient pas du tout dit il
asian indoor pays au total il ne devrait
pas être ici dit celle ci
avec plus de voir jeu comme depuis trois
nuits 17 albertaine qui a fait le voyage
de grand prairie je n'ai eu que trois
heures de sommeil chaque nuit
un jubilé qui pour un moment fait
oublier les tracas quotidiens et
l'actualité avec son lot de mauvaises
nouvelles l'inflation la pandémie la
guerre en ukraine comme si le
royaume-uni s'est arrêté dans le temps
pour marquer cet anniversaire
la reine est absente pour la plupart des
festivités mais reste présent dans le
coeur des britanniques qui vont à
célébrer tout au long de la fin de
semaine d'ailleurs un grand concert est
prévu demain soir pour lui rendre
hommage et elle risque une fois de plus
de le regarder dans le confort de sa
résidence ici à dévoiler guerguisse
radio-canada londres